uh no sorry the I wonder if I can change
it from wide screen that sucks uh you'd
have to back up to see the ground
that further that way oh yeah I can
point it that way oh yeah there you go
yep I can see it just barely don't move
to don't move any
forward there you
go yeah it's been
rolling
pretend it's heavy pretend it's heavy
pretend it's
heavy back up back up back
up keep doing it maybe he'll just like
through the legs through the
legs
pick it up on your back pick it up on
your back yeah put it on your back and
like try and stand up with it all
Heavy yeah there you go there you go
there you go there it is there it is
there it
is now turn toward us a little bit and
then try and make it look like you
pooped
it now you can't see your pants anyway
yeah there it is there it is there it is
Let It Drop right behind you yeah
y yes with the pants pulled up with the
flow pants pulled up
awesome